this was another step up in attacks
inside the capital
more homes hit more lives lost
they've been so resilient
but this is really taking a toll
tears yes but a steely toughness too
we'll keep ourselves together he says
tears on his cheeks we will remain
strong
the city was roused early again with
multiple strikes in all points around
the capital and they're expecting a lot
more over the next few days
the sound of battle is unavoidable now
in the capital but this army chaplain
called it an unequal fight
this isn't war he says this is
international terrorism war is armies
against armies but when armies attack
civilians this is international
terrorism
the mayor called it a dangerous moment
and immediately slapped a 35-hour curfew
on the capitol
how would you describe the spirit of the
ukrainian people and your feeling about
this
the spirit right now everyone is angry i
talk to the people they don't want to
live
in this activity
bring much more
energy to everyone and everyone
understand don't want to live want to
depend defend our city
they are meeting this onslaught with
fortitude cleaning out their broken
homes and just getting on with it
some have sent their families and
children outside kiev because they've
known the russian military was homing in
on this city
oh these are all the children's toys
yeah the children things all but the war
has reached right into their living
rooms and balconies now
my parents still in kiev
living on left bank
[Music]
my sister too
but we've
still there
you're still here yeah
and
i'm not afraid
because i know it's
i believe our victory
the residents know their homes and their
lives are collateral damage in the
battle for this the prize their capital
city but they're not bowed
i don't think i am brave but i don't
want to leave my city i don't want to
leave my country and uh
if it will need be i will take a shoot
to take a gun and
go
go to fight and
kill russia
the capital's mayor expects more of this
and has warned that russian activity is
expected to substantially increase over
the next 48 hours and he's urged his
fellow residents to be wary
he and his brother believe the russian
military is very close right now and
they've no intention of going anywhere
you can throw a stone
and he's a russian soldier i'm not even
kidding
and besides he points out they have
increasingly few options now
we have no other choice
but defend our city our capital and our
country
what is the other choice
run for life
we don't have father life
our life is here
we didn't invade anyone they came to our
home and killing our men women and
children there's a deepening frustration
amongst ukrainians as time runs out for
any concrete outside help with soldiers
civilians and journalists being killed
and injured
this must be devastating for anyone who
comes from this area um what are you
what are your thoughts about how much
the international community is not just
devastating
this is war behind me building where
civilians were killed by the russian
rocket and this is not just the first
and not the last
it doesn't matter
who you are on the ukrainian soil now
with a press bench
a little girl a boy
an adult
man or woman
or an old person
you're a target
from russia from russian army
but so many of kiev's residents refuse
to be intimidated despite it all
come and have coffee with us she's
saying to our crew when will he be open
she takes barely a heartbeat to think
about this
[Music]
soon she says
even with the russian military closing
in on them their spirit seems
unbreakable
alex crawford sky news in kiev